- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our homeroom live stream.
We have a very exciting
guest, Rehema Ellis,
who is the education correspondent
for the NBC Nightly News.
But before we get into that
what promises to be very
exciting conversation,
I'll give my standard announcements.
One, a reminder that
we are a not-for-profit
and we can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
Also want to make a shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up
to help Khan Academy,
especially during the
COVID school closure,
what can only be described as a crisis.
Where Khan Academy's traffic
has gone up dramatically,
our costs have gone up.
So special thanks to Bank Of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly and Novartis to
help close that gap.
But we also need more,
especially as we go into 2021.
Last reminder, there is a
version of this live stream
in podcast form.
Homeroom with Sal, The podcast.
Get that wherever you get your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited
to welcome Rehema Ellis
to our conversation today.
Rehema. Good to see you.
- Nice to see you, Sal.
- There's so much I want
to talk to you about.
But the two things I think
will be really interesting
and I encourage everyone
listening or seeing this
on YouTube and Facebook to ask questions,
especially in these two
dimensions, but really on anything.
You're the education correspondent.
So you're really seeing on the ground
what's happening in schools.
So I encourage people to
ask questions about that.
But also just your life journey
as a very successful journalist.
Any questions people
have on that, as well.
But maybe a good place to
start is just where are we?
You know, what are you seeing
I know NBC Nightly News
is going to be doing a whole series
on understanding how teachers
are adapting to COVID.
What has been some of your
biggest takeaways so far?
- One of the things that is
my big takeaway is I hope
that people will gain
a greater appreciation,
respect and recognition,
if you will, of teachers.
As all parents, and I'm a parent myself,
find ourselves at home with our children,
we love them dearly and
care for them dearly,
but some of us are not the best teachers
for the ones that we love.
And we are seeing a tremendous
amount of appreciation
for what teachers do.
We care for our children
because we love them,
but we entrust them to
a stranger to care for
some 25, sometimes 30
children in a classroom.
And for those who do it
with such magnificence
and such passion and concern,
they are really superstars in
terms of our children's lives.
And ultimately in terms of
the life of our society,
because a society to prosper
requires, demands really,
an educated population.
So, that's one of the
things that I'm seeing.
I'm hearing a lot of people talking about,
"Geez I had no idea how hard
it is to be an educator."
- Absolutely.
It's funny when you were saying,
when you kind of reminded yourself,
I love my children dearly.
You expressed what a
lot of parents express,
but especially during COVID,
where we remind ourselves that
we love our children dearly.
But maybe my children are a
little bit harder to deal with
on a full day basis than
I originally expected.
- For an untrained parent
who was not trained
as an educator, you start to
see this is really challenging.
And so this appreciation,
I think is wonderful.
And I'm so happy to be a part of
what NBC Nightly News is doing.
And that is devoting a
whole week to what we call
Teacher Appreciation, to
really highlighting some
of these superstars in
the field of education.
And there are a lot of them.
- And it might be obvious, but you know
to NBC's credit, NBC has always kind of
put a real emphasis on education.
What was the catalyst
for doing this focus?
A whole week on, not just
teacher appreciation,
but how teachers are
navigating the crisis?
- Well, one of the things is
the crisis that we are in.
It's not just something that's
outside of the classrooms.
Even our children are
not in the classrooms.
It's not just something that's
not happening to children.
It is happening to children, even though
children are not among
those whose numbers are seen
as the fatalities of this dreaded virus.
But children are being
severely impacted by it.
Not being in school, a place
that's a social environment.
It's a learning environment.
It's an opportunity to
learn how to not just
learn your ABCs, but how to
communicate in a community.
When we don't have that,
that's really damaging.
It's really impactful on children.
NBC recognizes that and said,
let's take a minute to see
what teachers are doing
to try and fill that very important
and large gap that's occurring
for so many of our children
as they're learning remotely.
- And, you know, I want to get into
some of what y'all will cover
but there's a question from YouTube.
Mr. Specter asks, "Ms. Ellis,
is it hard finding stories?"
And, that's actually interesting
because this is kind of the intersection
of the two things I want to talk about.
When y'all decide that you want to do
let's say a week of reporting on teaching,
especially the crisis,
what's the process for y'all?
How do y'all find out
the interesting stories
and how do you kind of surface
the real human element of it?
- It is varied.
Sometimes it's complicated
and sometimes it's easy.
Sometimes we'll see what
our colleagues have done
on other platforms, be it newspaper
other television programs, et cetera.
And we'll say, "Oh my gosh,
that's a great story."
If we're looking from
local television programs,
we'll have a producer, a camera person,
a correspondent like myself
in a particular city, and say
"I saw this story on local television.
This would be the kind of story
that we should tell our
viewers all around the country
and indeed all around the world."
And then we sometimes
just call up schools.
Call up school departments.
Call up local community
agencies and ask them,
"What's going on in your community
that might be of interest
to our viewers from coast to coast?"
So again, it's complicated sometimes.
And the process varies in terms of how we
zero in on stories.
- And what are some of
the stories, you know,
not to give away your
whole week of reporting,
but I'm assuming you've already started
to record some of them.
Are there any that have
really stood out to you?
- Well, of course mine stands out to me
but they all stand out to me.
We had one on the air just last night
about a teacher in Wisconsin.
Who was so concerned about the fact that
she wasn't able to be with her children
because everything was shut down.
It was being done remotely.
And so she decided that she
was going to infuse some
of the sense of architectural
skills that she didn't have.
At least she didn't know she had,
but she found out that she did.
And on her classroom,
on her school grounds,
she built a tent with a tarp,
the seats, the desk, the
chairs, the chalkboard,
books, and brought her
classroom from home.
Everybody was at home.
Now they're in this classroom outside.
It was so successful.
The whole school now has
their classrooms outside.
So, there's ventilation.
There is separation.
Because they have a big property.
That kind of thing doesn't
work so much in the inner city
but it works wonderfully for
this school in Wisconsin.
And kudos for that teacher for saying,
"I'm gonna try something that
I never thought of before."
That's exactly what's
happening with the story
that I'm gonna have on tomorrow.
It's about a science
teacher in Washington, DC.
His name is Jonte Lee.
And you can see from some of the pictures.
He's concocted this
arrangement inside his own home
because he said to himself,
"We got a problem here
in need of a solution."
And as a science teacher,
he said, "What can I do?"
Listen to a little clip of our story.
Chemistry and physics is hard to do
when you're face to face.
How did you imagine you would
continue teaching remotely?
- Well, as you could see
that I turned my kitchen
into my classroom and that my
kitchen also became my lab.
The only way that I was able to think of
doing it successfully was to make it as
interactive as possible.
And what better way to
teach chemistry then
from the kitchen?
And because we do
kitchen every single day.
No, we do chemistry every single day
in outside of our kitchen
is heat, acid, bases.
- He's now become known
as The Kitchen Chemist.
Because what this teacher
did, he went above and beyond.
He decided that if I'm going
to have lab experiments,
my students need to have lab supplies.
So taking money out of his own pocket,
he went and bought the supplies
and then delivered them personally
to each one of his 35 students.
And in so doing, he's
putting up these videos.
These videos have gone viral.
Not only around the country,
but around the world.
People are tuning in to Mr. Lee's classes.
And I said to him,
I didn't even think that
students would want to do that.
He's got perfect attendance
with his 35 students every single day.
Once again, I think a testament
to a teacher who cares
so much about his kids,
that he said I'm gonna figure out a way
to continue to connect with
them, even if it's remotely.
And he has a good time
doing it. Lots of fun.
- Well, I mean, that's
a fascinating story.
And you know, my selfishly,
my Khan Academy hat,
we're actually doing a big push
in middle school and
high school chemistry.
And I think you might've
identified someone
that we have to call up
to help us out with that.
- In fact, Sal, he's already connected.
He goes to Khan Academy
for some of his advice
and some suggestions
and ideas that can help him with his kids.
So you two already linked.
- Well, yeah, I mean, it's
great if he can leverage us,
but I think we might need to leverage him.
So that's a separate
thread that we'll take on.
So a ton of questions are coming out
and a lot of it about, you know,
your life and your life journey.
So before I get some of these questions,
I am always fascinated
by hearing the story.
I think a lot of kids, if
when they're 10 years old
or 15 years old, they say, I
want to become a journalist,
or I want to be on NBC Nightly News.
Your parents will be like,
all right, maybe, you know,
your parents are kinda thinking about
the probabilities in your head.
And it's like, well, don't why
don't you just go, you know,
do something that, you
know, go be an engineer,
go be a doctor, a lawyer,
or something like that.
School teacher, where
there's a clear pathway.
Did you always know that you were gonna be
a journalist, especially
a journalist on TV.
And, how did you get to where you are?
- I absolutely did not know
that I was going to be
a broadcast journalist.
It was not until my
sophomore year of college
that I had a professor and
her name is Andrea Russian.
And she looked at a paper that
I wrote about James Baldwin.
And she said to me, I
was a sociology major.
She said, "The conclusion you came to
in the paper was not exactly
right, but the way you came
to that conclusion and wrote
about it was brilliant."
I respected this teacher so much,
also an African-American woman,
that it changed me at that
point, because she said
I would encourage you to be a writer.
I was just blown away.
And I think it's one of those things
about the real value and importance
and significance that a teacher
can have in someone's life.
We've been profiling such a teacher,
also on Nightly News this week.
A young man who was
growing up in a shelter.
And he had a fourth grade
teacher who kept telling him
you can be anything that you want to be.
He's now paying it forward.
And he's a fifth grade teacher.
So teachers are outrageously important
in a young person's life.
So, in my sophomore year of college,
I was inspired to take
some journalism courses.
I did not know what I would do with them.
But I took the journalism courses.
I then had internships,
which are so valuable.
I did, I had a college radio station.
I was the host and the producer
and the anchor of this
college radio station.
I was doing public affairs programming.
And then I also wrote
for my local newspaper.
And then I went away.
I went to East Africa
for a couple of years
'cause I wasn't quite sure that journalism
was the thing that I wanted to do.
And I came back after I got
accepted to Columbia University
Graduate School of Journalism.
And that then launched
me into doing radio.
And from radio I did television.
And in television, I ended
up in New York here with NBC.
Not what I had planned, but
I am enormously grateful
for where my journey has taken me.
And all because of a
teacher who inspired me.
- You know, that has a lot
of parallels to Lester Holt.
Lester Holt was on this show.
I always feel embarrassed
calling people who
do real shows, calling this a show.
He was talking about being
kind of this radio geek
even when he was very young.
He would pretend to do a radio show,
even when no one was listening.
And eventually he did.
So it sounds like radio is
a really interesting path.
Before I get to some
other folks questions,
what do you think allowed
you to really stand out?
What are the skills that you think you,
and I know it's an awkward
question to answer,
but what are the things that
you think have really stood out
and allowed you to get to where you are?
- I actually think timing is everything.
Timing is everything.
The time that I had with
that professor in college.
Having the time to have radio stations
who's looked at me and said,
"We will let you do this."
Then getting accepted to a great school.
And from that great school
I got a scholarship.
And the scholarship, it
was with what was called
Westinghouse Broadcasting back then.
And they wanted to, I think,
cash in on their investment.
They gave me some money
and they wanted to see
if they get follow through on it.
And I ended up in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania doing radio
and then to television.
I had a fantastic mentor
who saw something in me
and encouraged me to do
things that I quite honestly,
unlike Lester, in imagining
myself doing radio.
I hadn't imagined myself doing it.
But, having an opportunity
to write and in radio.
I loved doing radio.
One of the strengths of it
is, you have to create images
with your words.
People can't see, but they can hear.
So all of the sounds,
the sound of my voice,
the sound of the voices of
the people whom I interviewed,
the sounds in the
neighborhood or the streets
where the places where I went.
Using all of those
sounds to craft a story.
It was fascinating to me.
And I, again, I think some of it is luck.
Some of it is being in the
right place at the right time.
Some of it is having people
who encourage you to go on
and do things that sometimes
you don't even imagine
that you can do.
And then also, I must say
having the parents that I had.
Who just always told me
that once I put my mind
to something, I could do it.
And so I've always followed that.
It just keeps me going forward.
- Were there any moments
where you've kind of
doubted yourself, where you felt like,
hey maybe I'm not cut out for this,
or I'm not gonna be able to make the dent
that I wanna have?
(Rehema sighing)
- Not really.
But the moment that I felt
when I was first starting
in the business, is that all
of the monumental stories
had already been told.
Vietnam had happened.
The Civil Rights Movement had happened.
Pearl Harbor had happened.
So what was I going to do?
A kid coming up in the eighties,
going into the business
And I thought my life
was pretty good actually.
And the world around me was opening up.
And opportunities for
people who looked like me
were beginning to open up.
And so what would the stories be
that I could possibly tell.
Boy was I wrong.
And there has just been
one story after another.
And here we are now, in the
middle of a historic moment
in terms of a pandemic.
I couldn't have imagined it.
And I don't think that anybody
else could have either.
But the minute you think that there's not
a monumental story to tell, life changes.
And it can be your story.
- Absolutely.
You know, there's a couple
of questions here about,
I'll ask both of them and
we can kind of merge them.
From YouTube, Smart Bear says,
"How do you include your
NBC life with your kids?"
I'm assuming they're asking
about kind of work-life balance.
And also from YouTube Niche786 is asking,
"What are some things that
you notice now in your life
after becoming a journalist
that didn't notice before?"
So generally speaking, you know,
life work balance is a
struggle for everyone.
I can imagine you travel a lot.
You're on the road a lot.
How do you make these balances
and how has it affected your life?
- One of the things that
happened when my child,
my son came home was,
to be honest with you,
it was a rebirth for me.
I began to see life completely differently
from how I'd seen it before.
And the things that worried
me didn't worry me anymore.
I was so consumed with
trying to make certain
that I gave my child
the best possible life.
And at the same time, I'm a single parent.
And so I had to keep working.
and I am so fortunate that
I've had wonderful people
in my life to work with me and to help me.
So it's possible that if the phone rings
I can get up and go to that destination
where the story is unfolding.
And that's about luck.
And I think it's also
about positioning yourself
in your life and asking, quite
honestly, to reveal to you,
to ask the universe,
to help me do the kinds
of things that I want to
do in order to balance
life with my work.
My work is enormously important to me.
I can't imagine doing anything else.
I really, I really love this job.
And I love my family.
And people say, "Can you have it all?"
Sometimes you can. Sometimes you can't.
Sometimes your child needs
to go to the pediatrician.
And a story is breaking.
But your child's needs to
go to the pediatrician.
Story. Pediatrician.
It really isn't that much of a hard call
to make if your child needs something.
And I again have been so fortunate.
I work for a company that also recognizes
that I am a correspondent,
but I'm also a human being.
And I think that NBC appreciates the fact
that I will give my all every
single moment that I can.
And when it's time to
take time for my family
I have to do that too.
That makes me a better journalist.
I think it makes all of
us better at what we do
when we can have a little compassion
and understanding about a
little one who is dependent
on us in order to grow.
So to that first question
about how do I balance it.
I balance it the best way I can.
But I also have help to make
it possible for me to do it.
- No, it's a powerful idea because I think
a lot of times when
people talk about this,
they talk about, oh you should balance,
like it's a trade off.
That, hey, you're gonna
take away from work
to become a better parent.
But to your point, especially
when you're reporting
about humanity, that element
that's going to make you
a better reporter to have that,
and a better correspondent
to have that aspect of your life.
I couldn't, I couldn't
agree with that more.
You know, we have a
limited amount of time.
One thing that I, questions, actually,
there's a lot of questions coming in.
I'll save one of these for the end.
But I am curious your views on just
the state of eighties and
nineties, when you know
the Nightly News was everything.
Now we talk about social media.
Oh, it sounds like I might've clipped off.
I would love your take on where
we are journalism generally.
You know, there's a lot of
talk about polarization.
People living in their bubbles.
Going on social media,
getting their own version.
At the same time, we still
have the Nightly News,
which is kind of the, you
know, which we've had,
the three major networks, you know,
since for many, many decades.
How do you see all of this evolving?
And how has it affected, you know
how y'all think about journalism?
- The way I think about it is that
this is we're in this
little bubble of infancy
of communication and information.
Technology is exploding.
Information is coming at us
fast and furious and constant.
And I often think of it,
and I don't mean this
to be disparaging in any way whatsoever,
so please forgive me if someone
attempts to see it that way.
I often think of it as us being very young
and almost childlike in the fact that
we are bombarded with information.
It's almost like a child in
a candy store who is hungry
for every single bit
of candy and sweetness
that they can find.
And it's all around them.
And ultimately the child learns
that there has to be a diet
of candy and other things.
Protein, other carbohydrates
and vegetables and vitamins.
You learned that.
But at the beginning, it's just
an explosion of excitement.
I think we're in that
explosion of excitement.
There's information everywhere.
And I'm in the information business.
So I would never be one to say
let's turn off the information.
But one of the things
I do think is important
is to understand and to get
a sense of media literacy.
To know the difference between something
that's just exploding at you,
and something that gives
you context to the content.
And I want all of us to
become really, really literate
and understanding media.
Question sources. Examine sources.
And maybe go outside of our comfort zone
and look at a variety of different things.
In so doing, I think we'll
become better educated
on how to use this wonderful,
wonderful opportunity
of information that we have available
to us right at our fingertips.
- It makes a lot of sense.
And maybe just to close out, you know
one last question getting
from YouTube again.
Actually another question from Niche786.
What some advice that you
would give to teenagers?
I guess some teenagers
who might want to go
down a path similar to
yours or people want to go
down any path.
What advice would you
give to your teenage self
or to any teenage self?
- Read everything you can.
Information really is power.
It also informs your thinking.
It informs your writing.
It informs your perspective.
So you have to read.
Sometimes we get just little tweets
and think that now I'm really informed.
Well, you might be really excited.
And maybe excited to go examine
something more in depth.
One of the things that happens
and was said to me when I
started in the business is that,
journalists, we're kind of
in a 30 minute broadcast
of nightly news.
We're a conduit of information.
We certainly do frame
what people think about.
But I hope that we
encourage people to say,
"Now let me decide what I
think about the information
that you have channeled
for me to take a look at."
And the only way we can do that, you know,
when you get a story, I hope
that people then will say,
"Let me read more about this.
Let me find out more about
that particular subject.
Even let me find more about these teachers
who are inspiring all of us
and how we might be able to
appreciate them a little bit more."
Not just on a short news
clip that we provide,
but going more, exploring more.
I hope that anyone who
thinks about getting
in this business will become a glutton
for information and all
kinds of information.
That's what makes what we
do powerful and important
to the people who are our
viewers or our readers.
- It makes a ton of sense.
Rehema, I want to thank you for joining
and I actually want to congratulate you.
You're getting a major
award, the Legacy Award,
from the National Association
of Black Journalists.
That's already been announced.
But you're going to get the
award I think in a few days.
But this is just another testament
to the importance of the
work and your career.
And thank you for being part of this
and giving us a little bit of wisdom.
- It's a pleasure. Thanks for having me.
- Thank you.
Well, everyone. Thanks for joining.
You know these conversations
always go faster
than I expected.
I could have talked to Rehema
for a very, very long time.
But definitely check out NBC Nightly News
and these stories that
really are incredible stories
on education and teachers.
And you know, for those of you all who are
gonna be future journalists,
I think you just heard a great role model.
To think about how you
might chart your career.
So anyway, I will see you at the next
Homeroom With Sal.
It's gonna be a Ed Talk
tomorrow with Brooke Mabry.
I will talk to you all then.
(interface beeping)